good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm at
the beach and it's very pretty here but
my vacation has been completely consumed
by this book the parable of the sower by
Octavia Butler which is the best book
I've read it I don't know in years
like every now and again I'll read a
book and literally feel like a spell has
been cast upon me that allows me to
escape the prison of myself and for a
little while I will not feel stuck
inside my own consciousness but instead
I'll feel like I have magical access to
worlds outside of me and I find that
feeling to be a tremendous consolation
and then when the book ends I'm left
with this weird wabi-sabi feeling like
I'm overwhelmed with the mysterium
tremendum of having seen and having been
seen and I also feel this big sadness in
my chest maybe partly because I know
I'll never get to read that book again
for the first time but also partly
because I don't know how long it'll be
until I come across a novel again that
properly turns me inside out now of
course I think the books that leave me
floored aren't always going to be the
ones that leave you floored but I do
think you would love this particular
book if you haven't read it already the
bear well the seller is a hard book to
summarize it's a coming-of-age story
it's also a dystopian novel about the
collapse of the United States it's about
race and class and gender and wealth and
it's also about how religions form and
even though it's more than 20 years old
Hank it is terrifyingly contemporary
right but so anyway throughout this very
page turning roaring adventure II novel
the narrator writes short poems about
her understanding of God which she
defines as change
I usually dislike that kind of
novelistic device but Butler is such a
beautiful writer that it succeeds
brilliantly like consider this
magnificent short poem Hank in order to
rise from its own ashes a Phoenix first
must burn I want to share just two more
lines with you first like The Great
Gatsby the parable of the sower begins
with a fictional epigraph which
concludes without positive obsession
there is nothing at all Hank one of my
favorite things about you is your
positive obsession aka your nerdiness
like you have this ability to be on
ironically enthusiastic and to find
stuff that you can be strongly in favor
of and you aren't the kind of person who
tears down without building up like when
we were in high school I felt like in
order to survive I had to create ironic
distance between myself in the world you
know like if you told me you liked a
band I would be like yeah their old
stuff was good but now they've sold out
or if you told me you liked an author I
would tell you what was wrong with their
work etc but Hank you've encouraged me
to let go of that and throughout my
entire adult life you've really been a
model for positive obsession kind of
even a guiding star at times so thank
you the second line is a simple one as
the narrator's life is falling apart she
writes kindness eases change Hank I'm
really sorry that lemon is dying I know
that she's just a dog but she's a great
dog and in the comments of your video on
Friday I saw so many people whose
kindness is easing this awful change it
made me think about lemons life like she
was a racing greyhound which often isn't
the best dog life but then when she
retired she came into your life and just
as you've made lemons life better she's
made your life better we often imagine
the world as a zero-sum game as a place
where good news for someone is
necessarily bad news for someone else
but I believe that kindness can change
that arithmetic and as evidence I would
point to the love that lemons life has
brought to you and to many the Internet
can be a hard place to find kindness
maybe especially right now but I believe
it's worth fighting for because I
believe it makes the world bigger and
that it eases the hard but inevitable
changes that define life nerdfighters
thank you for your kindness
Hank I love you I love lemon I'll see
you on Friday